70 Palm boy found a macro Maven she
joins us to kind of untangle the
insanity here
I'm not you know Stephanie I have to say
you're one of the very few people who
called this early and said they're going
to be
tragic and distorting effects of
flooding the American economy with fake
money from the Federal Reserve and I
think I think you're right
yeah well it was hardly a radical uh
conclusion to draw when you slather on
layers and layers of debt on an economy
and encourage people to take Reckless
risk and then you ratchet up interest
rates at the fastest rate in history I
mean God knows we the the surprised is
that it took this long for the bodies to
flow to the surface and honestly Tucker
this banking thing is particularly
remarkable because of the the level of
impunity that the banks evidenced and
you've talked about you know this whole
diversity Equity inclusion and in the
woke agenda and this idea that you know
banking doesn't need to be boring you
know you used to want to get away from
the banker at the cocktail party now
that you know throwing confetti and he's
got a lampshade on his head and he's the
life of the party but the reality is
these problems at Silicon Valley Bank
and signature you know their pursuit of
these woke agendas may make them well
let's hope exceptional I mean hopefully
their these videos aren't pervasive to
the entire banking sector although they
may very well be but ultimately the
entire banking sector did the same thing
and that is that they watched their
deposit base wither over the last 12
months while the Fed was Raising
interest rates because people like you
and me looked at it and said why am I
putting my money in the bank and getting
zero when I can buy a treasury bill and
get three four five percent as the FED
kept raising rates so their deposit base
was shrinking at the same time all those
assets that they held that you talked
about last night the treasuries and
whatnot were declining in value and they
sat there and they did nothing about it
Tucker and they didn't just do that for
one month or two months which might be
excusable but six nine months go by and
the problems are getting worse and worse
and they did nothing why did they do
nothing because they knew all along when
this day came the bailout would be there
for them so the impunity of the spanking
system is beyond but they've been taught
there are no consequences for
mismanagement and this ridiculous uh you
know all these ridiculous woke
priorities which have you know you
should actually when someone comes in
and presents a business idea and wants a
loan you should be looking at whether
it's a viable business model not whether
it's you know some sweaty teenager in a
hoodie with some hair brain scheme that
you can throw money at without
consequence but this is where we are and
and sadly
um I think we're just at the beginning
of this because the companies that FB
svb and these other Banks lent money to
are all going to go belly up just like
the clients of svb started to do
hopefully they'll spare us the moral
lectures they already pay half the tax
rate we do in a lot of cases it's a
little it's a little much I would say
Stephanie pomboy I appreciate it coming
on today thank you so much
thank you so much
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight